Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Welcome to
Camp No Counselors.
S'mores!
You're gonna get it really cheap
on this deal.
If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
That's awesome.
...they'll invest
their own money...
How about this deal --
30 bucks a unit, forever.
Perpetuity.
Kevin is back!
...and fight each other
for a deal.
But what happens, then,
when you need a real partner?
O'Leary: Do you have a better
offer, Daymond?
I might.
Okay, well, then,
get it out.
The entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
We almo--
We almost lost our house.
This business isn't
profitable yet.
I think the valuation's
out of whack.
I want you in my corner.
If you give me 25% of
the business, I'll do it.
It's the biggest moment
of your life.
Don't screw it up.
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Daymond John dominated
the fashion world with FUBU.
Now he's the branding expert
behind multiple global brands
generating billions in sales.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
Tichauer:
My name's Adam Tichauer,
and I'm the founder and Head
Camper of Camp No Counselors.
Camp No Counselors
is an all-inclusive
sleepaway camp for grown-ups...
Dodgeball!
...where adults get to play
like kids again,
competing in activities
like dodgeball,
three-legged races, zip-lining,
and we even have
a giant Slip N Slide.
[ People cheering ]
I wasn't always a Head Camper.
My first job was in finance
in New York City
working in a cubicle.
I was working around the clock
and just needed to get away
for a weekend.
I decided to rent out
a sleepaway camp
and invite my friends
and they told their friends.
90 people signed up,
and by the end of the weekend,
we were all best friends, and I
knew I needed to do it again.
Cheers.
My business means everything
to me.
I quit my cushy job in order
to take a risk and do this.
I can see the beginning steps
of something really great
happening,
and I can tell that
it's positively impacting lives.
The ability to let go
and be whoever you want to be
is something that kids
get to do every day.
We want to bring that feeling
to adults,
and camp is the perfect place
to do it.
♪♪
My name's Adam Tichauer,
and I'm the founder and Head
Camper of Camp No Counselors.
I'm seeking a $300,000
investment in exchange for
7.5% equity ownership
in my business.
Now, Sharks,
please close your eyes
as I take you on a journey
back in time.
Imagine yourself
as a 10-year-old
stepping onto the bus for your
first summer at sleepaway camp.
Mmm.
This is gonna be
the summer of your life.
Now, please open up your eyes.
[ Laughs ]
What I've done is I've bottled
up that feeling and experience,
but I'm delivering it to adults.
I introduce to you
Camp No Counselors,
your all-inclusive
sleepaway camp for grown-ups.
At Camp No Counselors,
we rent out sleepaway camps
in their off-season
and invite adults
to come back to camp
for fun-filled weekend getaways
with their best friends.
During the days,
you'll play like carefree kids
doing all of the fun,
classic camp activities
like archery and wakeboarding,
rock climbing, and zip-lining.
And in the nights, you'll roast
marshmallows around a campfire
and party like grown-ups,
dancing in the stars to
unforgettable bands and deejays.
I've got a little treat
for you guys
to get your in
the right mind-set.
-S'mores!
-S'mores.
-You smell it, don't you?
-[ Laughs ]
So, we start our mornings
usually with Bloody Marys
and mimosas.
-Whoa.
-Ooh.
Here, you can grab a beer,
and don't forget your postcard
to write home.
There you are.
Thank you.
Here you go, Lori --
a mimosa.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
-A s'more. You're welcome.
Here you go.
You know, Adam,
you are one class act.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
-Salud.
-Cheers, everyone.
-Mm.
Salud.
Welcome to Camp No Counselors.
Greiner:
So, this is very clever.
Where are you doing this?
Currently,
we're doing them in New York,
Los Angeles, Chicago,
and Nashville.
Are they in rural areas,
or...?
So, we work directly with
summer camps,
so they're usually, you know,
a couple hours outside
of the city.
We provide round-trip
charter transportation.
We provide open bar
all weekend long.
All of the meals,
all of the accommodations,
all of the activities, and it's
a very turnkey operation.
How much is it?
It $478 on average
for the all-inclusive
three-night weekend.
Are you using
the actual counselors
that work there during
the normal season
-to do this for you?
-Yes, we are.
So, we -- we work directly with
the camp's infrastructures.
So, we work with the camps
right before the kids arrive
and right after the kids leave,
so it's incremental income
for the camp owners.
So, your only overhead
is marketing and the rental.
-That's it.
-Like what?
-What's the average age?
-Give us an idea.
Average age is 30 years old.
I used to be
a camp counselor.
-So was I.
My speciality was
the long portage.
-No, no, no. Long portage.
-At what camp?
-15-day trips.
-Emma Kaufmann Camp.
I'm a masterful canoeist.
I'd take 20, 30 people out.
-We portage for miles.
-Oh, my God.
But here's what I learned.
Here's what I learned.
Sure.
It sucks.
[ Laughs ]
There's a lot of insects,
you get eaten alive.
It's tough work.
Today, I like a mint
on my pillow when I go to bed.
[ Laughs ]
I don't want to be anything
near a camp.
I don't know why these people
would do this.
Let's go back to the business
for a second.
Tichauer: Sure.
What were your total sales
last year?
Last summer, we did four camps
and we grossed $160,000.
And now this year,
we're doing 11 camps,
we're having 1,800 people,
and to date,
we've grossed $730,000
and are projecting to do
$800,000 this year
with a profit of $165,000.
We're starting to do
some corporate retreats,
but the biggest way
that we're gonna scale it
is do simultaneous camps
over a given weekend.
And so, what's your typical
camp cost you direct?
If it's $478 that
somebody pays...
Right.
Our cost is $278.
Our profit is $200 per person.
Is one of your risks
that the camp itself says,
"I've watched you do this
three years in a row.
What do I need you for?
Why don't I just
do this myself?"
Tichauer:
I've created the demand for it.
Time Out New York
did a piece on us
that had 560,000 people
share that on Facebook,
and they have never had
that many people
-share an article before.
-That's huge.
Adam, have you raised
any external money?
We've taken on loan of $100,000,
but besides that, nothing.
Adam, I don't see anything wrong
with your business model.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
I particularly hate camping.
I've made a rule
in my "Shark Tank" deals
that I use the products
that I invest in.
I would never go there.
I just don't want to even think
about this idea. I'm out.
All right. Thank you.
What do you need us for?
Obviously you know
"Shark Tank"
is an amazing PR vehicle,
right?
Right.
One is the capital
to scale our infrastructure
into new markets
and to market and create demand
in these new markets.
But you have enough profits
for that.
This year,
we'll do $165,000 in profit,
and that'll be enough
to hire the teams
to do these new markets.
That will not be enough.
We really want to scale
this thing quickly.
Next year,
I'm planning on doing 30 camps.
Yeah, but it's not
ringing true, Adam.
Every camp
is self-cash flowing.
In the event that we try a
market where we don't have that,
we need to put up-front capital
into those advertising
and public relations campaigns
in those local markets.
Herjavec: But how much?
How much does that cost?
Let's say I said to you,
"Let's go to Chicago."
How much would you spend?
We spent $2,000 on advertising
for Chicago this year.
Okay, but that -- I think
that's Mark's point.
I'm sitting here
the whole time thinking
what a great business
for you.
How do you invest
in this?
Again,
we need this up-front capital
to get into these new markets
and the-- th--
But you just said you spent
$2,000 to get into Chicago.
That's it.
We only did one camp
in Chicago.
I want to do three, four,
and five camps
starting next year
in these new markets.
But you don't really need
money to do that, do you?
But you're generating
that cash flow. You're
generating that cash.
Because all you're doing
is renting a place.
Adam, I think -- I think what
we're really getting at is --
Sure.
...if your valuation
is $4 million...
$4 million.
...and you did $800,000
this year...
Yes.
...and you're offering us
7.5%,
it's -- all you're trying
is basically gold dig.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out
and the others question
Adam's motives in bringing
his sleepaway camp for adults,
Camp No Counselors,
into the Tank.
Adam, I think -- I think what
we're really getting at is,
if your valuation
is $4 million...
$4 million.
...and you did $800,000
this year...
Yes.
...and you're offering us
7.5%,
it's -- all you're trying
is basically gold dig.
Because you're basically
saying right now
you don't really need
anything from us.
I'm here to close this deal
because I want to scale
this operation
so we can grow a lot quicker
than we are right now.
W-W-Well, then,
why do you put that --
Why do you feel
that valuation is accurate?
The way I valued it is based on
next year's profit
to be $800,000 in profit,
so at a 5x multiple.
Can I give you the money
next year?
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary:
Adam, just out of interest,
how are you planning on
returning this capital?
What are you gonna do?
When -- If --
If and when the business sells,
since we'll all be partners,
we'll all reap the benefits
together.
So, you think you can sell
this as an event business
to somebody that's gonna scale
it even beyond what you do?
Correct.
This could be a Tough Mudder,
this could be a Color Run,
this could be in every country,
in every market
across the world.
By 2019, I'm projecting
to do $35 million in sales.
Um, I'm not interested
in a long-term exit.
I like to ring the register
every quarter or every year.
Right.
And I think you have some
liabilities ahead of you.
You mentioned a couple
of Tough Mudders
and things like that,
but those aren't
overnight experiences
where alcohol is involved.
Right.
And with those two issues,
Uh, I just don't think
it's for me, so I'm out.
Thank you.
Greiner: Here's the bottom line
for me.
I think it's very clever,
seems like a lot of fun,
but I think the valuation's
definitely out of whack.
I just don't find it
investable for me.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I love camping.
I think it's a great idea.
But money is not always the
solution to grow every business.
Right.
And I -- I don't see how my
money is gonna add value to you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
O'Leary:
One Shark left, right?
Adam, I-I think
it's a brilliant idea.
-Um...
-Mark, I would love to --
I'm not here to beg or whatever.
I would love you
as a partner in this.
Man, we would take it over.
Well, you're -- you're gonna
take it over.
-I mean, look --
-I know.
-You're a party promoter, right?
-I want you in my corner.
-Yeah.
No, I'm serious.
I'm serious here.
At the end of the day,
you're a party promoter.
Let him beg.
I like it.
The issue is that 7.5%
is just nothing.
If you're making $1 million
a year in profit
and you start to
pay distributions,
I get 75 grand a year.
Right.
It doesn't matter for you.
It's just not --
It doesn't move the needle.
There's just not
enough upside.
So, ho-- One,
how do we make it an upside deal
so you're --
you're excited about it?
I mean, if you give me 25%
of the business, I'll do it.
I can't do that.
Yeah.
You know, it's just --
It's not a knock on you, right?
It's a compliment.
Is that an offer, Mark?
The only way I would go
as high as 25%
is if everyone came on board.
Herjavec: For $300,000?
Yeah, you know what?
That just makes it sound shady.
-Because I want --
-And so --
Again, because I want to
scale this thing
with the best people
in the -- in the business.
Yo-- I'm out.
Thanks.
Thank you so much, Adam.
Thank you. All right.
I like the groveling.
I like groveling.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Good idea.
Kevin, did you just always
get beat up at camp?
What's a portage?
How do you not know what
portaging is?
-What is it?
-I don't know what that is.
You carry the canoe
on your --
It's when you carry the canoe
by yourself.
Between lake to lake.
Up the mountain.
See that mountain?
I can't see you running with
a canoe on your head.
And you know what?
While you're doing it,
beavers are snapping at you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 4,
Samantha Meis and Connor Riley
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for their coffee subscription
business, MistoBox.
And we hand-select only the very
best of coffees to send to you.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we were fresh out of college
and just starting out.
Doing the deal with Mark
put us in the spotlight
but also revealed a major issue
in our business.
Preferred coffee taste
is subjective,
and we realized that customers
wanted to make
their own decision
and at a better price.
We had to change something
or our business was gonna fail.
So we went to Mark.
Mark told us the way
we were operating
our business
was not sustainable.
We listened and decided
to completely overhaul
our subscription service.
Now coffees are completely
personalized
to our subscribers' preferences
at a lower price.
I think 2016 is gonna be
our biggest year yet.
It's been three years
since making our deal,
and we have more than
$2.5 million in sales.
Growth has been
through the roof.
-Hey, guys.
-Hey, Mark.
Cuban: I just wanted
to say congratulations.
The honest to God truth
is I didn't know
if you guys would make it,
but your margins are growing,
your customers are happier.
You guys deserve
so much credit.
Give yourself a little pat
on the back
and then go back to work.
Awesome.
Thank you, Mark.
-We appreciate that.
-Thanks so much, Mark.
Meis:
This business is our baby.
We had this crazy idea
in college,
and now we've grown it to
a full-fledged business.
We are so thankful for
our "Shark Tank" experience.
MistoBox!
[ Cheering ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a unique way
to keep one of your most
valuable possessions protected.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kenny Lerner,
born and raised
in Brooklyn, New York,
living the dream
in Long Island.
My name
is Matthew Harris,
and I'm currently
in North Carolina.
Our company is the EVP.
We're looking for $50,000
for 20% equity in our company.
You've all seen
the devastation in the nation
and around the world
with floods.
It's not if the next flood's
gonna come, it's when.
And we definitely know
it's gonna come.
They've been coming more
and more frequently.
The thing is -- what to do
to protect the vehicles?
Does anybody have
a plan in place?
Probably not.
Most everybody has a safe
in their house
to secure their jewelry.
Maybe they have an emergency kit
in their car, in their boat,
in their plane,
in their helicopter.
But, really, nobody has
anything prepared for cars.
Well,
we have the solution,
and we want to show you
how it works.
But we need a volunteer.
And, Robert,
you're a car guy.
I'm a car guy.
Give us a hand.
You want to me to
drive it somewhere?
We're gonna have you
drive it somewhere.
All right.
Hop on in.
All right, so you're just
gonna get in here
and you're just gonna
ease the car in.
[ Car door closes ]
Start it up?
It should be started up.
The blue light's on?
[ Laughs ]
In drive?
He's the car guy.
Harris: Just ease it in.
Slowly.
Real slow.
Greiner: Bye, Robert!
-You're going into --
-Aah!
Keep it going.
[ Chuckles ]
It's a car condom!
I can't see a thing.
That's all right.
Hey, how do I get out?
[ Laughs ]
Oh.
You're just gonna duck down
a little bit.
[ Chuckles ]
Ta-da!
It was electric.
I didn't know it was on.
John:
Amazing. Amazing.
-It's so quiet.
-Amazing!
There it is.
Ta-da!
Now it's waterproof,
flood-proof.
So it's a ziplock baggie
for your car?
Basically.
And how much do you
charge for it?
We charge between
$250 and $350.
Is the idea,
as soon as it starts raining
and you think you're gonna
have a flood,
you drive your car into the bag?
I would think the weather
would be a little more extreme.
If you know a high tide
is coming or a Nor'easter,
you can't bring your car
to higher ground --
I like that as a car cover
in general
'cause the car covers
come off half the time.
So, Kenny,
I have a lot of cars.
I had a Ferrari,
a Lamborghini, or a Rolls-Royce,
and I bought a product
that looks
almost exactly like this
15 years ago.
It's a clear bubble.
Right.
You drive the car in.
It blows up around it.
They've been around
for a long, long time.
No electricity.
Oh, I see.
Your power's out.
You're stuck.
You need two people.
In less than 1 1/2 minutes,
your car is completely safe.
So, the difference between
your product and that product
is you simply zip it up
at the back.
Right.
What's your backgrounds?
What's your relationship?
Um, I'm a graphic artist
of 20 years.
Kenny was a repo guy.
Kenny, you must know Kevin.
You repoed something
from Kevin over time.
-You're still repoing?
-No, no, no.
I gave up repoing.
I'll tell you why
I did it for 20 years,
and then at some point,
when the economy started
affecting middle-class people,
I started
getting assignments
for my neighbors
and my relatives,
and it was no longer
the scammers or the --
-Too close to home.
-The uptight banker.
Very close to home.
And -- And I felt my karma
shifting.
You didn't like taking
good people's cars away.
No, I didn't.
I cried every night.
Oh, that's brutal.
It was just a terrible,
terrible thing.
And I had just had enough.
Wow.
What do you estimate
the market for this is?
If everybody knew about it,
how many would buy it?
We live in New York.
We saw what happened with Sandy.
Yeah.
People lost their homes
and their cars
all in the same day.
Yeah.
A lot of people.
Had -- Had this product
been available at that time,
we think we could have done
a very, very brisk business.
What are your sales?
Our sales -- We coordinated
this entire project
being on here
with you guys.
Oh, this isn't gonna be
a good answer, is it?
No, it's gonna be
a very good answer.
All right, well,
let's have the answer!
Because you're gonna get in
really cheap on this deal
if you like the concept.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a new one.
-If you like the concept...
-I love you.
-It's a pre-sale.
We're practically
giving it away.
Hang on, Kenny,
is this a "get in on the ground
floor" opportunity?
This is "get in
on the ground floor."
This is a business...
'Cause, Kenny,
you have no sales, right?
We sold 150 of them for cash
like that till we ran out.
-That's it.
-How long did that take?
Pfft. Two weeks.
And you sold them where?
Body shops, car s--
car clubs,
anywhere where
people gather.
Guys, let me get --
let me get the ball rolling.
I don't see this as a business
that's going to
scale into a $10 million,
$20 million,
$50 million business.
I just don't.
You can build
a nice business,
but a nice business is not the
same as an investable business.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Kenny, I don't know if it's
gonna work. I-I'll tell you why.
People don't really think about
their car in an emergency.
People think about their home.
They think about
their loved ones.
The idea of buying this
in case there's a flood,
I think it's gonna be
challenging.
When something does happen,
for them to go buy it,
it's the last thing
on their mind.
I wish you all the best.
-Thank you very much.
-I'm out.
-I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm not a car enthusiast.
It's not really my thing.
Um, I think your packaging
there, while it attracts my eye,
I can't tell well exactly
what it is from a quick glance.
Okay.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
O'Leary: I like this.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll give you the 50K
and I want 30 bucks a unit.
John: Hmm.
It's a royalty deal.
You get the 50K
to build some inventory.
Um, obviously I'll help you
get the word out.
Go sell for two weeks
and you make your 50K, right?
You know. Can we sell --
What's your offer?
My offer is very simple.
I give you the $50,000
and I get $30 a bag forever.
-Forever.
Perpetuity.
Kevin is back!
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
The point is, I get --
-He's the repo man.
-The reason this works,
and you can talk to
any of my royalty guys,
they love it
because my whole team
is incentivized to sell units.
That's all we do.
We crank up our social media.
I go on television with it.
I talk about how great you are.
And I save cars, which is nice.
And I put one on my car.
Is that what you'll do
with this product?
You'll go on TV,
you'll promote it?
Oh, yeah. I go nuts.
I'm incentivized
to sell a lot of units.
So, what do you need
the money for?
Forever's a long time,
Kenny.
It is.
The money is secondary,
Daymond.
They're selling
car condoms forever.
We need you guys.
Harris: Yeah.
We need credibility.
We need connections.
Do you have a better offer,
Daymond?
I might.
And Matthew, you're doing
something else, right?
Okay, well, then, get it out.
I'll give you the 50 grand
for...
and we'll split the business
1/3, 1/3, and 1/3.
And what would your marketing
plan be, please?
Oh, you want me to sit here
and lay out a marketing plan?
I'm just curious
what your ideas are.
Daymond,
do you have a résumé?
-[ Laughs ]
-I know.
I should submit the résumé.
I'll -- I think I should
actually interview Daymond
before he takes this job.
[ Laughter ]
Do you have experience
in the retail market?
Um, I might. I might know
somebody who knows somebody.
[ Laughs ]
Unfortunately, when you sell it
to a large company one day,
you will leave 1/3
of the profits away.
I get nothing.
Cuban: And unfortunately,
you won't be able to sell it
to that large company
'cause they're gonna say,
"Royalties forever?
Are you kidding me?"
No, no. I --
You'll never see your company
with a royalty on it.
I might --
I'm a reasonable man.
Does that royalty stop at
a sale when we all cash out?
Well, I have to get some return
on my investment, right?
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
How about this deal?
'Cause you're -- you're
a reasonable guy.
All right, Kenny?
I look at it this way.
[ Laughs ]
It's the setup.
Wait for it.
Wait. I'm thinking.
-That's a first, too.
-It doesn't make --
It doesn't make sense for me
to give you 50K
and then just get 50K back.
Why am I doing that?
Right.
I'll give you the $50,000.
When I get 200K back, I'm gone.
So I got the thing
off the ground.
-I sell, sell, sell, sell, sell.
-Hmm.
And so the royalty stops
after I recoup $200,000.
But what happens, then,
when you need a real partner?
I mean, guys, that's --
That is a real partner.
That's concerning to me
'cause right now,
he will give you the injection.
Why do you -- This guy is asking
for 1/3 of your business.
Yeah, and you want a partner
with skin in the game.
Yeah, think of it, guys.
You said that you wanted
somebody you could turn to.
For -- For source of revenue
or source of cash,
okay, you can argue
Kevin's is okay.
But when he gets his 1,000 --
you sell your 1,000 units,
he's gone with the wind.
Yeah, that's not true, Kenny.
He's gonna be really --
-We'll work out a new deal.
-Yeah, 'cause what's his return?
He has no equity.
He's gonna be really
incentivized to drive the sales.
They came in here looking
for a quick --
1,000 unites. He said 1,000
units and he's out completely.
Kevin's your guy.
I will make sure you'll
sell 1,000 units quickly.
And I'm not gonna try
to make sure you sell
1,000 units quickly.
I like your partnership.
I'm gonna try to make sure
you sell 100,000 units quickly.
-'Cause I'll be a partner.
-Ooh.
You've thought about it.
You got two offers.
What would you like to do?
I appreciate your offer,
but I'm going with Brooklyn.
Ah!
What?
Smart guys.
I appreciate that, man.
Thank you.
Thank you, all.
Congrats, guys.
-Thank you.
Kevin, you didn't
get that offer.
You have to go inside there.
[ Laughs ]
That was rough.
Whew.
Lerner: I used to be in the
business of taking cars legally.
And now I'm in the business
of saving cars,
and it's a very,
very good feeling,
and I'm glad to have
this opportunity.
Narrator: Next up
is a young entrepreneur
seeking to grow the popularity
of her favorite sport.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Rachel Zietz,
and my company
is Gladiator Lacrosse.
I am seeking $100,000
in exchange for 15% equity
in my company.
Lacrosse is my passion,
and because
of my competitive nature,
I'm always striving to be
the best --
on the field,
at school, and in business.
My parents weren't huge fans
of me throwing
my dirty lacrosse balls
against the walls of our house,
and they definitely didn't
want me breaking any windows.
So, I bought a backyard lacrosse
goal and a rebounder.
I spent hundreds of dollars
only to have them fall apart
very quickly.
I knew I wasn't the only
lacrosse player out there
who was let down
by the available equipment.
So, I decided to design
and manufacture my own,
and thus, Gladiator Lacrosse
was born.
At Gladiator Lacrosse,
we know what you need to take
your game to the next level.
We provide affordable equipment
that withstands
the constant punishment
that competitive
lacrosse players deliver.
Lacrosse is the fastest-growing
sport in America.
And who wants to dominate this
space with Gladiator Lacrosse?
If you would allow me,
I would like to provide
a quick demonstration.
Let's see it.
So, the rebounder allows you
to practice your throwing
and catching skills.
It's a trampoline-like surface,
and you just kind of
throw against it.
And then the goal.
I rip some nice shots on there.
[ Laughs ] Good job.
Would anyone like to try it?
John: I've never played
lacrosse before.
Cuban: Go for it.
All right.
Zietz: Here.
It's super easy.
Okay. So.
[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
-Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
That was really good.
I'm not gonna --
I'm not gonna test my luck.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, hey, hey.
Good job, buddy.
Yeah. So, you haven't invented
a new product.
You've invented
a better product?
Zietz:
A better version, yes.
I was very frustrated
'cause I would buy
my competitors' products
and they would constantly rust
and tear and be completely
destroyed, like, after a month.
How old are you?
I am 15 today.
Get out of here!
And you're only 15?!
Thank you.
How old were you when
you started this?
I was 12 years old
when I started this business.
12?!
Yeah.
Oh, back in the day.
[ Sarcastically ] You're not
doing enough with your life.
You got to get going.
[ Laughs ]
Who helped you
and how did you figure out
manufacturing
in a better way?
Well, luckily, both my parents
are entrepreneurs,
so I was able to seek them out
for advice on business.
I also participated in
the Young Entrepreneurs Academy
and I met a lot of mentors
that helped me along the way.
Did you parents put
any money in, or...?
Yeah, they gave me a loan
for $30,000 that is paid back.
Yeah!
And how much --
And how much have you sold,
over what period of time?
In total, I've done
over $300,000 in sales.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, baby.
-Wow.
-That's awesome.
And that's in about three,
four years?
That's since January of 2014.
Good for you.
How do you sell it?
I sell on Amazon,
eBay, my site.
I sell in a couple
of specialty lacrosse stores,
and I also go
to local tournaments
and I sell there, too.
What's so unique about
your products
that differentiates it
from your competitors?
Well, I've become trusted
and known for being high-quality
and an affordable price
in the lacrosse community.
Not only am I the owner of this
company, I'm a client, as well.
[ Laughs ]
I purchase these products.
I use them every day
to improve my game.
Unlike my competitors
who make products
for all different kinds
of sports
and probably don't
play lacrosse.
How big's the market,
the entire market?
It's -- The entire market
is, like, well in excess
of over $100 million.
$100 million.
So, y-you're basically 1% of it.
What -- How big do you think
you can get to?
I hope to dominate
the entire market,
but I feel that as I expand
my product line,
people will not only
just buy the rebounder,
but they'll buy the rebounder
and let's say, a pair of socks,
or the balls to go with it.
Add-ons and things
of that nature.
How much does it
cost to make?
The rebounder costs $66.
The goal, $38.50.
And what do you sell it
for, Rachel?
I retail the rebounder
for $249.95
and the goal I retail
for $149.95.
How busy are you with
running the business?
I do have excellent
time-management skills,
as I've been able to...
[ Laughter ]
That's one of us, yeah.
Yeah. I've been able to manage
school, business, lacrosse.
But I also have one employee
who handles fulfilling orders,
does marketing,
and takes customer calls
while I'm in class.
Full-time employee?
Who is that?
She's a college student.
So, Rachel, you got
a lot of stuff going on.
Walk me through
a typical day.
Yeah.
So, at 6:00, I'll wake up,
and I'll start
working on the business.
Then I'll take the bus
to school.
I have some time to work there.
[ Chuckles ]
Then I get to school.
During my free periods
and lunch periods,
I'll handle customer calls,
or I'll fulfill orders.
And then I go to
lacrosse practice.
Are you captain?
I am.
I figured. [ Laughs ]
And when I get home,
I have dinner with my family,
and then I go to my room.
I'll do homework.
Very important.
[ Chuckles ]
And then I'll work on
the business some more.
Then the phone will
start ringing from Asia.
-[ Chuckles ] At 2:00 a.m.
-Yes, I do.
I take Skype calls at night.
What are you gonna do with
the $100,000, Rachel?
Well, I need the money
to increase my online
and retail distribution.
Actually, right now
I'm in discussions with Walmart
about selling there.
Secondly, I want to create
a sales team
to go out to these tournaments
and sell at the tournaments
nationwide.
And the third thing I want to do
is I want to increase
my product line to include
things like sticks, goggles.
-Well, can you --
-For inventory.
You need the money
for inventory.
Inventory
and to increase the channels.
Let's say you could get
to 30% of the market.
That's not unreasonable
for a quality brand.
That's
a $30 million business.
No way on Earth
you can do that between school
and dinners with your family
and everything else.
That's the --
That's the challenge here.
So, at the end of the day,
who runs the show?
Well, I'm going to be the head.
I'm gonna be the visionary
and the strategic person who
watches over all my employees.
As I expand, I will hire people
to handle the specific,
day-to-day aspects
of the business.
I-I think the fact that you are
the brand, you play the game,
it's so credible.
When people look at
which product to buy,
they're gonna buy it
from a player.
You know, I'm really torn.
Uh, I'm really torn.
It's sort of a hobby for you
right now, with great potential.
That's what it is.
I'm just torn.
But I'm out.
Thank you.
Cuban:
You deserve a lot of credit.
You found a niche.
Brilliant.
But the challenge for me
is I don't know lacrosse.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
But I think what you're doing
is phenomenal.
You set a great example,
so you deserve a lot of credit.
Thank you.
Your presentation
was fantastic.
But I just don't think you need
the money at this point.
I'm out. Thank you.
What happens if you
don't get the money?
Well, I'm going to continue
working harder, and I'm gonna --
have to keep reinvesting back
to get the containers.
I have to order
more containers.
I think that's the best thing
for you to do.
I think I'd be doing you
a disservice by investing money
and taking part of your precious
company that you've built.
So, with that, I'm out.
Thank you.
Greiner: You know,
I look at you --
It affirms what
I've always believed --
Women were built
for business.
I-I'm actually
humbled by you,
because there's nothing here
I would say you should change.
It's like you're doing
everything right.
I don't think that
I could add value,
because it's a space
I don't know.
For that reason,
I'm going out.
But I'm super proud of you,
and everything you've done.
Thank you.
Congratulations,
and happy birthday.
Right. Do it yourself.
Happy birthday.
Thank you.
You did a great job.
Greiner: Happy birthday.
Thank you.
♪♪
After watching "Shark Tank" with
my family almost every week,
I think it was so amazing
to actually be on the show.
Even though I didn't get a deal,
I hope that I inspired a bunch
of other young entrepreneurs
to start businesses
and follow their passion.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a modernized version
of a favorite arcade game.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Brad Baker.
I'm from Cincinnati, Ohio,
and my company is VPCabs.
I'm seeking
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
Everyone loves
the classic pinball games --
the lights, the sounds,
the clack of the bumpers.
Pinballs bouncing to and fro.
But then the digital revolution
happened,
and pinball faced extinction.
VPCabs puts hundreds
of pinball games, old and new,
at the mercy
of your pinball prowess.
By completely replacing
the physical guts and components
of a traditional pinball cabinet
with a high-end gaming computer
and multiple
HD LED playing screens,
you'll be able to choose
from hundreds of pinball games
in just a matter of seconds.
With advanced physics coding...
[ Sighs ]
O'Leary: Just the biggest moment
of your life.
Don't screw it up.
[ Chuckles ]
With advanced physics coding
and our feedback system,
you'll feel like you're
playing the actual game.
[ Flippers clicking ]
All the clicks, knocks,
sounds, and shakes
are right at your fingertips.
You can even shake and tilt
the machine
to simulate
your last-minute table bumps.
With VPCabs, you get hundreds of
games at a fraction of the cost.
And with our web-connected
platform,
you'll be able
to make the machine
easy to operate and to update.
Life is a buffet,
and pinball can be, too.
So, Sharks, who's hungry?
Would anybody like to
come up and try?
Cool stuff, Brad.
All right, all right.
It's on.
[ Laughs ]
Baker: You can choose
from a bunch of games.
Just go ahead and hit
the "Launch" button.
[ Flippers clicking ]
This is actually better
than traditional pinball.
-Kind of cool.
-You like that?
-It's pretty cool.
-Cool.
-That's cool.
-Is it cool?
It's cool.
Come look at this one.
-How's the old one feel?
-Where's the -- [Chuckles]
Because it was built in
a digital platform...
Whoo!
...it'll do more than just
your classic pinball.
Like,
on some of the games,
you'll go from playing
pinball to
chasing somebody
around the screen.
-Many questions.
-Ahh.
[ Laughs ]
Baker: [ Laughs ] Excellent.
I have many answers.
I'm still on
my first ball, man!
Okay.
O'Leary: So, Brad,
is this play for consumers,
or do you want to put it into
commercial establishments?
What's the plan?
I've owned an audio/video
business for about 15 years,
and my brother
owns a huge arcade.
One day, he asked me,
"Hey, I heard about this cool
digital-pinball technology.
I've got an old pinball cabinet
that doesn't work.
You think you could put
some monitors in it
and we could turn it into
a cool game?"
So I thought,
"Man, that's awesome."
So, I got a cabinet
and gutted it out,
and we put some monitors in it
and had a really rough,
rudimentary
digital-pinball machine.
It just really snowballed
from there.
People from the arcade
were like, "Oh, my gosh.
Could you build this for me?"
And within a few weeks,
I had, like,
an order
for eight pinball machines.
And...
the economy at that point,
in my home-theater business,
was-- wasn't that great.
We're in Cincinnati.
The market was still recovering.
And, uh,
we had been struggling in --
in the home-theater business.
And, uh, we were, uh...
Sorry.
We almo--
We almost lost our house.
Um, and, uh, I was charging,
like,
$4,000 or $5,000 to make
a machine for somebody.
And, uh -- And from the money
that I made off those machines,
I was able to go my bank
a week before
they were gonna foreclose
and pay my mortgage in cash.
Wow.
Uh, it saved my family.
So, you sold eight machines
to start.
What are your total sales
today?
So, in a year and a half, uh,
we have done...200 units.
And, uh, close to $750,000.
-Whoa.
-How many macho-- Wow.
What does one machine cost?
So, our machines vary
from -- right now,
from $3,000 to $9,500.
-Wow.
-What?
This machine here retails
for $7,995.
And we sell this machine 50:1.
How are you selling these?
We do trade shows.
Lots of trade shows.
In a two-day trade show,
our best two-day is $100,000.
So, Brad, walk us through
your business model.
Let's -- I understand
you're selling these
to consumers direct.
Yes.
So I'm assuming a 50% margin
on that at least?
The way that it works
right now -- uh, for example,
our $7,995 machine,
uh, my bill of materials
on that machine is $2,686.
Big question.
Protectable?
There is not anybody
that we know of
that's anywhere near
what we're doing.
We've got a really high-end
gaming computer in there
with video cards,
we use 8 to 16 gigabytes of RAM.
We custom-cut our own cabinets
on our own CNC machine
that we designed so that our
displays slide in a certain way.
So you guys are
a systems integrator?
Yes.
Are you making a profit
right now?
Well, so, for 2014,
I showed a net profit
of only about 12,000 bucks.
Wow.
Okay.
What was your gross profit?
-Now let's add -- add back in --
-What was your gross profit?
Gross prof-- profit
was around $70,000.
That's it?
So, about 10%.
Yeah. And, you know,
we were --
Is there any cost
to the software?
We pay a license fee,
uh, for --
How much, roughly?
I-It's -- It's up to
15% of the sale...
-Whoa.
-...of the sale of the game.
Okay. So, $2,600,
plus you pay
a software-licensing fee
of another $1,000.
You're at $4,000.
You're selling them at $8,000.
Retail, yes.
And we push them at trade shows
for 6,000 bucks.
Are you taking any cash out
to pay yourself?
Uh, I have not paid myself.
If you pay yourself,
a normalized salary for you
of, let's say, 80 grand,
this business
isn't profitable yet.
It -- It is not profitable yet.
I am putting every dime back in.
I'm probably buying things
to grow the business
that I maybe should have
waited a little longer for.
And I believe we have a product
that can scale beyond
just your average pinball buyer,
because a lot of people
are afraid to buy pinballs
because of the maintenance
and because it's only one game
and their kid's gonna get
bored with it really quick.
So, Brad,
I own 10 pinball machines.
Fantastic.
And you can buy them
for about $4,000 or $5,000,
and they feel great.
Yours felt better.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
But, Brad,
here's the problem.
The kids, they didn't get
the same excitement from it
as they do with
online games.
When we go to trade shows,
we have lines at our booth, and
kids are all the way around it.
Kids aren't gonna buy this.
You're gonna sell it
to old guys like me
who like pinball
because it's cooler.
Parents are buying this
for their kids nonstop.
For me -- clever idea.
Great idea.
I'm glad that it helped you
get out of a difficult position.
Baker: Sure, sure.
But for kids, 'cause
they all have little devices
with thousands of games,
and they can hold it
and carry with them.
And so I don't think
they care about
the huge, big, interactive
experience all the time.
I don't see this
scaling really huge
because there's just so much out
there in gaming people can do,
and so easily.
Digital pinball is
the future of pinball.
It's changing
the pinball market.
And for that reason, I'm out.
And w-- Thank you.
Thanks for your time, Lori.
I have to bring reality
to all your enthusiasm, okay?
Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
It is not worth $2 million.
It's nowhere near that.
I respectfully disagree
with you.
It's a break-even business
right now.
You really have no way
of paying me back.
I hope you can continue
to sell them one at a time,
but it's not investable.
Uh,
I appreciate your input.
I'm out.
Thank you.
First of all, the guy's been in
business for a year and a half.
You're building
the business.
Who cares what the profitability
is at this point,
and who cares what
it's worth?
Nothing proprietary at all.
That's not true.
Baker: I believe we will be able
to get some patents.
Zero.
Here's the challenge.
Absolutely nothing.
Here's the challenge
with the business.
You don't make the most vital
component of it the software.
I'd love to get there.
Tell me, how are you gonna
go from 200 machines to 400?
We want to push trade shows
further out west.
I really want to
get into distributors
like the stores
we're selling now.
They love our machines.
We're only in a few stores,
so --
And there's a thousand
of these stores.
Brad, look. I don't think
the kids are gonna buy it.
I don't think it's
gonna go that way.
I wish you would have
come up with a strategy
to find guys like me.
Can I te-- say one thing?
With the commercial side
of this business,
what has happened in the past
is most all of the big
arcades -- Dave & Buster's,
Chuck E. Cheese,
all the big ones --
they've gotten rid of pinball
because they're
too much maintenance.
And we have the ability to
get back into those places...
I don't agree with you.
I don't --
...in a big way.
And that's a hu--
Brad, I don't share your vision
for the commercial side of it.
This is a high-end,
vintage type of business.
I'd really like to do both. I
love what I'm doing here, but --
I'm out.
I'm trying so hard
to find a reason to say yes.
All right.
Right.
Just say it.
Let's do this.
Oh, I wish it was
that simple.
I disagree with Robert.
While you'll sell
to vintage stuff,
that's
the low-hanging fruit.
But what I see is a platform
for gaming
that's much more tactical
than using a joystick at home.
-A platform? A --
-Let's bring on a programmer
and make our own games.
Well, but see, but that's part
of the problem. Right.
You got to be kidding me.
Kids are gonna walk up to
this thing and play it?
Like crazy.
Every show, like nuts.
You know, that's the difference
between us, Robert.
It's huge. It's crazy.
You see something, and you
can be 1,001, and that's cool.
I see something,
and I want to be the first
at doing something
to change the game.
I'm changing it.
But you're not, though,
and that's the problem.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Mark and Daymond
are Brad's last chances
for a deal for his
digital-pinball machine company,
VPCabs.
The direction
you've told me is not it.
Your vision is for
a bigger business.
If you had come in and you had
lots of technical expertise
and said, "Here's where we are
as a platform,
and here's where
the custom is."
But you don't have that.
I would have to do it.
That's the problem,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
Whew!
Thank you for your interest,
too.
Appreciate it.
Daymond:
Now, I'm not as old as some
of the other Sharks up here.
-[ Chuckles ]
-So, I was raised,
and I bought a couple
of those games --
Donkey Kong, Crazy Climber.
They were digital games.
You know, he's kind of --
You know, when he was young,
there was pinball
that was out.
When he was young, there
was "Catch a Cavegirl"
or something like that.
[ Laughter ]
But, um, I believe that I may
be able bring value.
I have a company, Craig's,
in creating these electronics.
Can you take
your expertise
and not have to do
all this building
and go out and hit every single
door and things like that...
Absolutely. Absolutely.
...and then I will
make the product.
That -- That's what I do best,
and that's what I love to do.
I love talking to people.
I love showing them my passion
for what I'm doing.
All right.
You know, I'm gonna
take a gamble here.
Y-- Because of -- You know,
because we can make this with --
with my company Craig's.
$200,000 for 30%.
Don't even think about it.
Will you -- Will you do 20%?
Oh.
-I'm willing to go 20%.
-Let him think.
Please. I'm gonna k--
I'm gonna kill it for you.
$200,000, 25%, we have a deal.
Deal.
-Done.
-Good job.
All right.
-Congrats, man.
-Thank you.
-Appreciate it.
-All right, man.
Congrats, Brad.
-Thank you.
-Congrats, man.
-Thanks, guys.
-Bye.
Whoo!
It's just overwhelming that
someone would believe in me,
a little guy
from Cincinnati, Ohio.
My wife's gonna be
really excited.
[ Voice breaking ] Uh,
we've worked so hard on this.
And it is -- You know,
it wasn't a make-or-break deal,
but it was just
one of those deals
that this is gonna help us
get where we need to be.